well,
today is the deadline for
all high university students to
be fully vaccinated,
how are you greeted by cristian casseres with
his brief newsletter on news now in
spanish, i tell you that the students
of an audi will be demonstrating in the
facilities to demand that they be
end the mandatory vaccination in
august the board of directors of the
university educational system passed this rule
if a student cannot prove that
they are vaccinated against kobe 19
then they will not be able to register for the
semester and I tell you that the airline
american airlines canceled more than 1,000
flights  on sunday after a run of
nearly 900 in the previous two days more than
a dozen flights were canceled
locally at the airport i stayed on
this morning last week strong
gusts of wind disrupted
travel in one of the busiest spots
in the  company we talked about dallas a a
spokesman for american airlines said he
hoped  hope there is an improvement for today
and tonight is going to be the last
chance you can visit
knight mary and spring mount this one still
has its halloween decorations and is still
serving some exotic drinks due
to the occasions the celebrations follow
as we can see there and we close with a
look at the temperatures we will have a
sunny day with temperatures
reaching 77 degrees for this afternoon we
will stay with highs in
the 70s for the rest of
the week temperatures will drop for
Saturday and Sunday am  cristian
cásseres with his brief information on
news now in spanish good day
[Music]